leaving everybody welcome to Development
Committee 22nd of March 2018
first of all our usual announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the nearest available exit
to the chamber our assembly point won't
be in the public car park at the side of
the Civic suite please don't delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please don't return into the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that the
meeting will be audio recorded and can I
remind you to switch off your mobile
phones or turn them to silent thank you
item 1 apologies for absence
they've been received from counselor
mrs. Shaw whose substitute isn't here at
the moment councilor melon who's been
substituted by counsel Lucas Gill and
counts to step toe who's been
substituted by councillor Webb okay
thank you
non-members attempting counselor mr. hoi
item 4 minutes of the meeting held on
the 22nd of February 2018 you're happy
for me to sign those as a correct and
accurate record of that meeting thank
you declarations of interest right there
on on item 6 has been withdrawn from
committee deferred for further
discussion between the officers and the
applicant there's nothing on the weekly
list item 8 so we just have the one item
tonight which is fairways garden center
home Bridge Road Raley sorry going on
without a deputy yeah yeah okay
so Katie thank you
members this site has a frontage on to
Hobart Road the northern boundary runs
alongside the Montefiore Avenue and
there are a handful of residential
properties close to the sites a couple
fronting Goldsmith Drive one on top
which road here and another on the
corner of Montefiore Avenue and Hall
Bridge Road the site is designated as
Greenbelt
and this is an extract from the
proposals map this the application site
is approximately where the lightest is
there so it's set within the wider area
of Greenbelt between the residential
settlements of Hall bridge to the north
and Raley to the south whilst being in
the Greenbelt the site is considered to
qualify as previously developed land as
there are a number of existing buildings
which are not in agricultural use at the
site policy DM 10 of the council's
development management plan allows for
the redevelopment of previously
developed land in the Greenbelt subject
to the consideration of certain criteria
I'm going to take you through the
existing developments at the site then
we'll look at the proposals and then
we'll go through the key considerations
of policy DM 10 which are key to the
determination of this application okay
just stop you for a moment their members
are I should have just mentioned at the
start there has been an addendum to this
can I just double check that everyone's
aware of that because it might be
relevant and mentioned during the
presentation okay thank you so members
this is the existing site layout plan
and it's orientated with whole bridge
road to the bottom of the screen you can
see that there are a number of existing
buildings shown white the majority of
which are towards the southern central
area with one of the most haunted
buildings to the northern boundary these
are the areas that indicated white sort
of ad hoc sporadic developments are a
number of containers storage containers
and a number of caravans at the site are
used residential e also
so this gives you a flavor of the
existing buildings on the site this
building is here towards the southern
boundary and it's a draw pitch roof
building the external finish of which is
a combination of glass and steel
corrugated metal adjacent to this glass
house sorry adjacent to this is the
glass house now also put to commercial
use and in the center of the site
there's a building which has a series of
low pitch roofs with a canopy attached
running almost the length of the
building adjacent to this building is a
single story building with pitched roof
with a conservatory attached to one end
and then the final building on the site
is located to the northern boundary and
a series of flat and pitched roofs
partly timber clad all the existing
buildings on the site a single-story I
take you just a few through a few
photographs of the existing site you'll
see here this is part of the existing
vehicle er access to the site with Hall
Bridge Road shown just in there in the
picture there these are a number of the
existing storage own containers and you
can just sort of make out the edges of
some of the the mobile home caravans are
used residentially again this shows the
extent of the hard surface at the site
and some of the metal palisade fencing
and some of the parking areas this is a
view looking southwards so hull Bridge
Road is is orientated here and these are
some of the single-story buildings
that's the conservatory attached to one
of them this is another view of that
building and there are a number of
commercial uses at the site within those
buildings and then that's one of the
kind of larger sort of single-story but
pitched roof buildings
[Applause]
the proposal is for 16 dwellings which
would be laid out in a circular pattern
around a central amenity space Vic Euler
access to the site would be off hull
Bridge Road using the existing access
each dwelling would have a private
garden to the rear and parking on plot
five different dwelling types are
proposed all of which are similar in
form featuring traditional pitched roofs
and a variety of external facing
materials the proposal is a mix of two
three and four bed dwellings just to
give you a flavor of them this is
property type a this is a four bed
dueling one bedroom at ground floor
three within the roof space and features
a gable projection to the front
elevation this is another similar in
design and form also a four bed dwelling
three sorry yeah also a four bed
dwelling with three of those rooms in
the roof space and then this is the
smaller dwelling type on the site which
is too bad both of those bedrooms in the
roof space quite modest in scale the
properties that are proposed
so back to the proposals map and the
site again is located at about here
policy DM 10 is the key Greenbelt policy
against which the proposal must be
considered this policy allows for
residential development a previously
developed land in the Greenbelt if it
can be demonstrated that the proposed
development would constitute sustainable
development subject to consideration of
various factors firstly policy DM 10
requires that the proposal is well
related to a residential settlement and
the site is closer slightly towards the
edge of hall bridge but also within
proximity of Raley to the south and
despite not being adjacent to built at
residential area it is not considered to
be isolated from nearby settlements
proposals must also be well related to
local services and facilities the
nearest of those to the site is a retail
store in Hull Bridge at the corner of
Ferry Road and lower road and then again
there is a small local parade of shops
just on the corner of ham bro Hill and
roars Lane to the south approximately a
thousand meters from the site the fight
is considered to have good connections
to the strategic road network with ready
access to the a 130 from rora Lane and
occupants of the site would be able to
use bus stops and bus services that run
along Hall Bridge Road and there's a
cycle foot way along Hall Bridge Road
that could provide access to local
amenities whilst the site is not within
the South Essex coastal towns landscape
character area it is considered that the
redevelopment of the site would not be
harmful to landscape character in this
locality given the existing built
development at the site and the scale
and the design of the development
proposed policy DM 10 also requires that
redevelopment proposals of previously
developed land would not have a greater
impact on the openness of the Greenbelt
or on the purpose of including land
within the Greenbelt than the existing
development which would be replaced and
the applicant has provided a comparison
which on plan forms shows the comparison
of the kind of hard surfacing at the
site so this is existing buildings are
shown in orange and grey is the other
hard surface the site's almost entirely
hard surface and then the proposal
obviously you'd have that the individual
buildings but actually a large
proportion of the site within
residential Gardens and then the central
immunity area would all be permeable
soft landscaped the income and income
the obviously this table is not visible
but the applicant has done a comparison
of the overall volume of development
proposed and the proposal is a reduction
by some two thousand cubic meters of
volume what the development would be
higher than the existing buildings the
proposed dwellings are still limited to
one point five story and not excessive
image height and given that the volume
of built form would overall reduce it is
considered that the proposed development
would not have a greater impact on the
openness of the Greenbelt than existing
the proposal is therefore considered to
be an appropriate form of development in
this Greenbelt location take you to the
site plan the density of development
proposed is some 14 dwellings per
hectare which is low compared to the 30
dwellings per hectare that would usually
be sought as a minimum to make sites to
make best use make sorry on sites to
make effective an efficient use of green
but land however in this case the low
density is accepted given the need to
limit the scale of development proposed
in light of the existing built form for
the benefit of Greenbelt openness and
character whilst the proposal meets
other policy considerations in respect
of garden size and car parking to name
but a few as detailed in the officer
report the proposal fails to comply with
the council's affordable housing policy
this is set out in policy H 4 of the
core strategy and requires a minimum of
35 percent affordable housing to be
provided this would equate to six
dwellings of the 16 proposed this policy
does however require consideration of
viability the applicant submitted a
viability appraisal which concluded that
it would not be viable to provide any
affordable housing or contribution the
council had the applicants viability
appraisal tested by an independent
consultant who concluded that the
development would provide or could
provide sorry a contribution of some 600
63,000 pounds the applicant has in the
course of the application now indicated
that they would be willing to make this
contribution however can despite the
counselors consultant indicating that as
the development is a high-value
residential scheme and that affordable
housing on-site is not considered
appropriate offices considered that the
applicant must demonstrate that
affordable housing could not be provided
on-site before a financial contribution
as a fallback were considered policy h4
is strongly worded in that it requires
affordable housing on-site unless
constraints make on site provision
impossible it goes on to state that only
in rare cases taking account of
particular site characteristics the
affordable housing contribution may be
provided by way of a commuted sum no
evidence of any discussions with
affordable housing providers has been
provided to support an argument that
on-site provision would be impossible
indeed the very spacious plots proposed
are only one possible proposal that
could work at the site whilst officers
are satisfied with the principle of the
proposed development the proposal would
not comply with policy h4 of the
council's core strategy the
recommendation is therefore one of
refusal for the following reason which
is slightly amended from that published
on the officer report and I'll read that
in full with us ok policy h4 of the
Rochford district council local
development framework core strategy
requires at least 35% of dwellings on
all developments of 15 or more units to
be provided as affordable housing
subject to viability whilst the
applicant has provided an affordable
housing contribution towards off-site
affordable housing the applicant has not
demonstrated that provision of
affordable housing on-site would be
impossible the proposal would therefore
for contrary to policy h4 thank you
councillor gooding I'm afraid as you
arrived after the presentation has
started won't be informed command of the
facts so you won't be able to vote on
this one but you will be able to take
part in the debate
we have a speaker on this one mr. Cavett
Calvin Hardin minutes I'll let you know
when you go good evening as as you've
had explained the the development is
bull debated by two residential roads
and and and the main hull Bridge Road
the gold Smith Road which is on this
side has two adjacent properties there's
one property on on Old Bridge Road and
there's nine properties down Monte Fiore
Avenue myself I live in Montefiore
Avenue and I spoke to eight of the nine
residents there's only nine residences
territorial
I've spoken to eight of the nine
residents are they will support this
application the north I have not been
able to have the opportunity to speak to
as it has yet on this and as far as I'm
aware there is nobody in there
Montefiore Avenue I can't speak about
nobody Delmont or ahem there's any four
names or any other interests other than
purely their own personal aesthetics for
this development the current situation
basically the site as as you've shown
visually there doesn't totally portray I
would classed as a blot on the landscape
to be honest it is it is it is not a
well-managed so I fight any means and
the advertising all because you saw as
you came out of the road that the
picture there the averaging on one side
if you look the other side they're even
worse the other side these advertising
hoardings do actually effect cars
leaving Monte forever you you cannot see
some of the whole poverty's road it's to
date fortunately we haven't had an
extant from that we've approached these
the owners at the site but they have not
taken these Holdings down
there is an also I understand there's
there's been a number of applications on
this site for our caravans three times
since since the 1990s has been refused
and then on 2014 it was approved for a
caravan sale site well I understand and
I've read in the echo this week as well
that there are actually up to about 13
or 15 residential caravans there now
unlicensed and we're under an eviction
notice for the length of April the site
is and there are a number of other
planning discrepancies on this site and
I'm sure your planning department will
kind of I'd you but they are currently
trying to deal with it and the builders
merchants on site the build is no
actually the back of the site they uses
it as much for a rubble dump the
merchants and the long Montefiore Avenue
we have a surface drainage ditch which
we as residents maintain we get a JCB
and we have to clear it all out the
motor time is full of building rubbish
another rubbish and a effluent coming
off of this site it's a it really is a
blot on the landscape the whole place is
poorly maintained as regards traffic
there's quite a bit of traffic flow
there are during the day and I would
think that this development there it
certainly wouldn't increase the traffic
life if anything in decrease the traffic
flow from the side as regards greenfield
and Brent our Greenfield a Greenbelt yes
it is in Greenbelt but it's almost
really it's more like a brownfield
within three back site it's and I can't
see that this development will be
anything destructive more destructive
than what the current site is
if you refuse this application on purely
social housing grounds you know that's
your choice it is it is an outline
application over there are bearing in
mind that there are a number of other
very larger sites around we've got 200
300 and potentially of 500 housing
development she's also socially housing
meet it seems to me that it'll be but it
would be slightly inappropriate bear in
mind that that this site meets every
other of your national and local
requirements it's just purely it seems
to be social housing no can I just just
in conclusion so I notice on your on
your agenda it states the council
residence or the heart of everything we
do
states the museum I'm sure it states on
every agenda you have with this
development borders to roads with
existing residents properties there are
not many residential properties anywhere
near around just these eight nine
properties in Monte Fiore Avenue I say
eight of which support this application
it been mining is an outline application
the residents of Goldsmith Drive I can't
speak for but I understand that they
made a submission regarding a the
proximity of two of units to their
boundaries I understand that's been
addressed so when you're making the
decision I'd like to consider the area
residents with a view to which the
resins are at the heart of the matter
thank you very much
that's the hole would you like to have
your say yes thank you
although it doesn't come into the whole
Bridgewater it does come out onto the
road which is on average more it's just
a few comments in relation to the
addendum in the comments and some of the
other points around affordable housing
and couple questions this is an outline
application it's an interesting one
because it's outline but the only
reserved matter appears to be the
landscaping so in fact although it says
outline it's essentially the same as a
normal application apart from
landscaping reserve so we should be
looking at the design of this which is
not normally the case within an outline
application that I think might be the
first I've come across like this again
this this is I think the su the SU
skeptic out so urban design comments are
quite interesting they refer to a lack
of a pathway or crossing there they're
referring to the design although I'd
hear what the residents say just because
it might not be it might be an eyesore
now it doesn't mean that what goes there
shouldn't also be good and he shouldn't
just we shouldn't just accept something
because it might look a bit better than
what's there in at the moment so I have
a little bit upset and the offices just
ignore everything said by Essex County
Council urban design and and dismiss it
saying that they believe it's
satisfactory I think the committee
should pay attention to the points
raised by the Essex County Council urban
design C and insist that the points that
are kept if you you don't do it now
there and it comes back we we've lost
because this won't be on this earth it
would have been approved without these
the points which are on page four of the
addendum um I have a question around the
affordable housing in the contribution
we have a stand of 35% i've not aware
that we've ever accepted or during the
time I've been on council accepted a
contribution can you confirm are we able
to accept a contribution
in in a practical sense are we in a
position that we could use that to
provide affordable housing for residents
and I know there certain schemes which
might be staying through but I'd be
interesting there and if there is a time
limit on any contribution given from
that the only other point I will raise
at this point well I can write is about
a Greenbelt issue on on page seven point
one of the main report it does really
refer some reason why Greenbelt exists
this in itself you may think isn't going
to be country 20 of those nothing the
officers indicator and report I I would
say this is the start that although it
looks like it's not very well developed
between rady and Holdridge there are a
number of houses there's a three roads
coming off the whole weed road which
have properties down them this will then
be another big site of 16 it just seems
to me that this is starting to draw the
two towns or village of whole bridge in
the town of Raley together I think
that's contrary to the point first the
second point French towns neighboring
towns merging into one or another and to
say and also I think to safeguard the
countryside from encroachment I know
means I agree with them the view that
it's not a dice looking site so I think
that should be a reason for refusal as
well let's see if I can ever ask for and
they were housing on a grateful thank
you okay members I think I'll lead on on
this one today we've got an application
site here which has been described and
we've seen some examples as not
necessarily being the tide lifts of
sites and possibly having issues to do
with the legality of some of the housing
on there but what it is now and its use
now shouldn't affect our reasoning for
what might go there instead
however the principle of housing on that
site is a releve relevant point because
further up the road we have a another
former agricultural site which has now
got a vast amount of different uses on
it and the precedent of this site may
have an influence on that although
that's not a definitive reason that we
can use it is something that we need to
bear in mind we come to the the the
principal reason for refusal about there
not being any affordable housing as as
counts the high as mentioned there is an
offer being made of around six hundred
thousand towards that at this moment in
time the council doesn't have a formal
policy or strategy for accepting that
money it is not our policy to do that it
is our policy to develop affordable
housing on a site unless there is an
exceptional reason why it can't take
place so if we were to consider
accepting that we will be making up
effectively rules and regulations on the
hoof of what to do with that money over
time scale how its how its applied and I
don't think that would be appropriate or
a safe method to go forward
the officers broadly speaking or
accepting the principle of development
on that site with an argument with
regard to policy DM 10 and if I can ask
you to look at page 7 point 10 section
five point nine and there are six points
there which relate to the interpretation
of DM 10 now I will go through them in
in turn is well related to a defined
residential development I don't think
that is the case at the moment in
paragraph 5 11
the the actual figures are there it's
it's approximately a queston between
home bridge and and and ham ham bro
shops that sought a distance of over
toward a kilometer is not a short
distance it's not the sort of distance
that you'll just pop up the road to get
something that's a get in the car job
and that's not the sort of thing that we
want to be promoting second point one
related to local services and facilities
the same argument real are apply there
it's got good connections with a
strategic road work Road network there's
a road that goes straight past that you
can't argue with that would promote
sustainable modes of transport well
there is a bus stop just a relatively
few yards up the road from there however
you cannot get to it and no part of this
this application involves the applicant
the provision of a footpath to the bus
on the side of the road that the
development is in you would physically
have to cross that road quite busy it's
40 miles an hour there and then cross
back again I don't believe on that point
it is properly connected I think the
only use that it's viable safely from
that site won't be the use of transport
I think the other two points you can
argue that it possibly is acceptable on
those but I certainly wouldn't be
putting forward an additional reason for
refusal that the application is not
compliant with DM 10 well our policy DM
10 so
in summing out what I've said I don't
believe that the the policy the policy
is is complied with sufficiently here I
think there are some issues particularly
around sight say say highway safety and
access the bus stop I think in the
background there is the precedent about
the principle of what's happening here
certainly I totally agree with the
affordable housing and coming back to
what urban design have said I think that
the principle of a closed in insula
development on that road doesn't offer
us good design once you get in there
maybe that's a different matter
but we're talking about the amenity for
the whole district and as you travel
down that home bridge road if all you're
going to see is a closed development
with a long long section of boarded
boundary treatment I don't think that is
particularly good so I'll now open it up
further I don't know whether anyone was
happy to second me on non-compliance
with damn turned cancer Mountain yeah
I'm happy to second you but also I just
wanted to ask in relation to what
councilor who I mentioned about the the
separate identities of hull bridge and
Rayleigh and if this is an infringement
that could be regarded as an
infringement on that thank you
yeah I I think that is also summed up
possibly in the first point of FDM turn
related to refined residential
developments its plunk in the middle
it's not related to either it's not his
own cancer Stanley Thank You chairman
I'll take heed of what you said and
we've got to also put in there that it
seems to be an ad hoc development in as
much as will will as conditions will get
round to this and will get round to
there and so on and so on
we don't seem to have all the
information that we require
and all agree that we're not in the
process of building homes for ourselves
that's the council in in process of
building homes with the with the money
that was put aside so I would agree with
you on a lot of those things the other
thing that really emerges from it is
that we have now got four ponds on that
site which again is is we seem to get
more ponds than we do houses if you see
what I mean in relation to it and I just
wonder why we get if we're going to have
children on that side which probably
what we will have in the wild from what
preventative measures are being put in
place of those it interesting you you
say that you say that one the the the
pond I believe is part of the the sons
management which is something right of
your particular street the like that
that I don't open up the landscaping is
the one item that is reserved
so the actual treatment of that area in
the center with the pond how it will be
managed how it would be made safe and so
on that is a reserved matter that
doesn't formally form part of this
application - no thank you that's the
hoc way yes on on the back of that is
seen from the addendum that the SADS
scheme is not complete although it
doesn't seem to be a full fully worked
up system for surface water drainage on
on the site and and that was another
matter that was brought up by an Essex
County Council there's another item that
was brought to my attention in reading
the report but I don't know if it's a
breach of policy and whether it be
something that
could be looked at as a matter of for
refusal but it does state that under
economic developments is that a
detrimental impact upon the community in
the economic prosperity of Riley in
relation to a loss of potential
commercial land available for
development and perhaps that's something
that we might need to think about me do
you want to just make that point sorry I
didn't have that on so in that regard is
it is it something that could be added
or is it not appropriate to be added as
part of this part of that possible
proposal for yeah it's it's having the
policy hook for that reason for refusal
and although there are policy to
maintain so it would be possible as it's
not an allocated employment site it does
make that argument less strong if you
see what I mean for that purpose
because it isn't designated or allocated
for that purpose but there are there are
potential policy hooks that could look
to you know retain small medium sized
businesses in such locations so there is
potential
the officers can tell you give you a
reason you have to offer offer it okay
I'll come to Council - counselor mrs.
Hart first doesn't meet the f6 open
design because there's no path and
there's no crossing in it and I just
wanted at the point out that if you come
out to that site you go right just up
the road from there there is an actual
nursery like when I say no she I mean
not school no children and shouldn't we
be because I mean at the moment if these
houses were to be granted then basically
you're asking them to try and cross on a
40 mile an hour limit road just to get
to the net just to get to the nursery
school I don't take what you say I'm
saying but as always we do have to be
guided to an extent by highways can you
and for 4.8 on page 7.6 clearly says at
the top from highway and transportation
perspective perspective the impact of
the approach proposal is acceptable to
the high highway authority subject to
the following conditions I think we're
going a little bit further with
particular reference to access to the
bus stop but I think as part of the
debate that we're having here this
evening
we've got concrete reasons that are
absolutely defendable the the officers
are noting the nature of what's been
said with particular reference to
economic development to toward highway
safety and the crossing of the road and
clearly if this application comes back
it's not just going to
drop on the left on the doorstep one day
it's going to be part of a much fuller
discussion with officers before it even
gets to committee and we would hope that
any applicant ease is wise in listening
to the officers the nature of the
discussion we're having here tonight and
ultimately any decision that we made so
members we have a really amended reason
for refusal printed on 2.77 we have a
reason for refusal also based on policy
DM 10 or the lack of compliance we have
a number of points around highway safety
around economic development around
precedent about the appropriateness of
the design in that location which has
been duly noted by the officers so can I
ask those members in favor of the
refusal on those grounds to please
indicate thank you that item is refused
and for good behavior